Myth: Injecting medicine straight into your
heart can be beneficial in some way.
Ah, the dramatic scene that ends with an actor
stabbing a needle straight into their heart,
narrowly escaping death and magically curing
whatever ailment just befell them.
While very dramatic, it’s also very untrue
and an exceptionally bad idea if your goal
is to get better.
In the end, it doesn’t matter whether or
not the medication attempting to be delivered
would actually work in the described situations;
this myth comes down to one thing: if you
stick a needle in your heart, you will bleed
to death from the small hole you just placed
there.
Just like a balloon, if you put a hole in
it, it’s really hard to keep the air from
escaping.
The other problem with this method of delivery
is your lungs.
The chances of you putting a hole in one of
them, as well as your heart, is pretty good.
Not only would you be bleeding to death, you
would be really short of breath while you
slowly died.
The truth is that there are much easier ways
to get medication to your heart.
Medication requiring a needle has two options
that are much better than a hole in your heart.
The preferred method is starting an IV and
giving it to the person through their veins.
Considering most people have their entire
blood volume pumped throughout their body
in about a minute (depending on a person’s
heart rate and left ventricular ejection fraction),
medication delivered this way would reach
the heart rather quickly.
If you can’t get the medication in a vein,
numerous types can simply be placed in any
muscle group and have it reach your heart
in under 5 minutes.
Currently, there is no treatment in modern
medicine that requires a doctor to stick a
needle into your heart.
The closest is called a pericardiocentesis.
This procedure involves a doctor sticking
a needle into the sac surrounding the heart
(pericardium), in an effort to remove excess
fluid that’s putting pressure on the heart
(cardiac tamponade).
They even take great care not to advance the
needle too far, causing it to rupture the
heart itself.
As they know, a hole in your heart is a bad
thing.
While the method of medication delivery in
this myth is easily debunked, it does make
one wonder what else about this treatment
presented in movies is also false (or true).
Never to be one that leaves a person wondering,
let’s break apart arguably the two most
famous Hollywood scenes that used this treatment
and see if we can’t reveal some other interesting
facts while doing so.
Scene #1- Pulp Fiction: In which John Travolta
needs to give an injection of “adrenaline”
straight into the heart of Uma Thurman’s
character, presumably altering the effects
of the heroin she just snorted, thinking it
was cocaine.
After stabbing her heart, she immediately
wakes up and is completely fine.
When a medical professional gives a person
an “adrenaline” shot, the medication in
question is called Epinephrine.
Epinephrine has many uses in medicine, including
cardiac arrest, allergic reactions, asthma
attacks, and helping with acute low blood
pressures, to name a few.
It’s a hormone and a neurotransmitter that
acts on several different types of nerve cells.
The response involves the stimulation of your
“fight or flight” nervous system (sympathetic
nervous system).
While beneficial in many aspects, it’s usually
never given in a heroin overdose.
Unless of course the person’s heart has
stopped, then maybe.
Even in that situation, you would also need
to preform CPR and defibrillation (shocking)
to be helpful.
Heroin is in a drug class called an opioid.
Other opioids include codeine, morphine, oxycodone,
methadone, and fentanyl to name a few.
(Aside: Heroin was originally marketed as
a non-addictive cough medicine by Bayer.
You can learn more about this in Episode #182
of this podcast: When Heroin was Marketed
as a Cough Medicine)
In any event, one of the biggest problems
with these types of medications, and usually
the cause of the person’s death in an overdose,
is respiratory depression or failure.
When the person takes too much, the person
can begin to breathe slower and shallower,
or stop breathing all together.
The heart will soon stop once this happens.
Giving a person epinephrine in this situation
wouldn’t help.
While theoretically you might get some respiratory
increase, although I can’t find any study
that shows this, epinephrine would wear off
long before the heroin, leaving the person
still dead.
There is, however, a medication that can have
the same effect as adrenaline did in the movie.
It’s called Naloxone.
Developed in the 1960s, it’s known as an
opiate antagonist.
It’s the drug of choice for treating any
opiate overdose.
When given, it will bind to the receptor site’s
opiate drugs do, in effect, knocking them
off the cells and not allowing the drug to
work its magic.
The effect is rather quick and nearly absolute.
It can take a person from not breathing and
unconscious, to completely awake and “sober”
in about a minute.
There can, however, be some complications
from using it.
The drug itself doesn’t last as long as
an opiate does, so there is a chance the person
could stop breathing again.
Due to the fact that the result is so absolute,
if the person is an addict, completely taking
away all of the effects of the opiate could
cause them to immediately go into withdrawals.
The results of those can be things like nausea,
vomiting, muscle cramps, diarrhea and seizures.
From the author of this piece’s personal
experience treating these types of overdoses,
he states that the two most common problems
are the person’s violence just after they
realize you took their “high” away, followed
almost immediately by them throwing up all
over you.
Don’t do drugs kids!
In the end, this movie had Uma Thurman’s
reaction to an antidote correct.
They simply chose the wrong medication and
a completely wrong delivery method.
Scene #2- The Rock: In which Nicholas Cage
has to inject Atropine straight into his heart
to counter the effects of VX poison gas.
In this scene, the movie makers got most of
it right.
There is such a thing as VX poison gas and
part of the treatment for an exposure is Atropine.
VX is classified as a lethal nerve agent.
Like most nerve agents, VX works by inhibiting
an enzyme called Cholinesterase.
The result is a build up of a neurotransmitter
called Acetylcholine within the body.
This build up causes an over-stimulation of
glands and muscles.
The results are things like dilation of your
blood vessels, slower heart rates and constriction
of the bronchioles in your lungs.
All of this happens while simultaneously you’re
subjected to what is known as SLUDGE- “SLUDGE”
being an acronym for excessive Salivation,
Urination, Defecation, Gastric irritation
and Emesis caused by exposure to the toxin.
If you become exposed, the toxin causes you
to stop breathing due to the over-stimulation
of your diaphragm (and many other muscles)-
all of this while leaking fluids from most
every orifice of your body.
The treatment for this does include atropine.
It also includes a drug called Pralidoxime.
Pralidoxime helps by reversing the effect
on Cholinesterase thereby helping to reduce
the amount of Acetylcholine in the body.
Atropine helps by competing with Acetylcholine
at its receptor sites, reducing its affect.
The recommended treatment for exposure to
this type of toxin includes the use of both.
The military, and some civilian emergency
services, use what is called a “Mark 1 kit”
that has both medications in an auto-injector.
No, it doesn’t inject anything in to the
heart for the aforementioned reasons.
The recommended sites are on the thighs and
hips.
While this movie did get some of the treatment
right, it got the delivery method completely
wrong, but a gigantic needle to the heart
is certainly slightly more dramatic I suppose.
Just don’t try that at home kids.